hi my name is greg alba and i am with
the real rejects uh i have i have seen
your reaction video as well we're in a
stream of people whose reaction videos
have been devouring
you guys are very very well spoken so
thank you for yeah uh thank you dad um
that just means the whole
world to me amber thank you so much for
taking the time to
talk with me for some reason i feel like
i really need to communicate this uh
i really love this movie like a lot
hey dakota uh thank you for taking time
to speak with me i mean this is the most
non-bullshit way possible
i really really love this movie a lot
and i thought you were just [ __ ]
awesome in the film
as well seriously thank you so much dude
i was like 15 minutes into this movie
and i i didn't even know i was going to
be talking to you and i was like damn
this guy's this guy's awesome oh that's
wicked dude it's gonna sound very
unprofessional but i really want to
communicate this holy
i love the out of this movie
wow thank you i really did i'm a fan of
this franchise and i said this out loud
uh when i was watching it i've never
cared so much about a main character in
this franchise like i was
i was so rooting for you and you were
just excellent not only were you badass
but you brought so much emotional weight
and um
i wasn't nervous when i got off the
invite but then i saw the movie and now
like i'm a little bit nervous to be
talking to her right now so
that's so cool
oh
thank you
that means the world i mean obviously
you know we worked really hard on it for
a really long time and like
stuff like that means so much to me
because you never know you go out there
you make a thing you don't know if
people are gonna care about it so thank
you thank you so much man that just
means the world to me it was so much fun
to make you know ride in the horse fight
and it was just a fantastic time and to
hear that you enjoy it i mean
it's just cloud nine for me i've never
been more excited to be part of a press
junket before just so i could tell you
that because
this movie was awesome i could ask
questions for an hour or i could just
spend the rest of this time
complimenting uh and reviewing this
before you guys because yeah
wow it was great i will ask real
questions i promise
so dan with with the usage of the
predator in this movie there was so much
of the time i got like this this genuine
fanboy sense of a director going man if
i made a predator movie here's how i
would capture it was there any
particular shots of the predator that
you had always imagined bringing a life
that you brought to fruition here i mean
it's just the overall sense
him lunging from tree to tree
is something that you sort of see in the
original predator kind of you know and
ever since then to me so often has felt
like it's a it's a professional wrestler
in a suit lumbering around
and i i was
the most anxious
to include the feral movements of an
alien creature um back into the
franchise
that was a huge part of it just merely
the way that he moved um
was exciting it was it was super
exciting for me
and you're right that
everything was like all right i'm doing
this kind of movie i gotta do it like
every time i was like i have to not be
mad at myself i have to love the scene i
have to love this thing that we're doing
you know so yeah i i thought you you
nailed it it was scary and imposing and
very like
beast
i could i really could talk about it for
forever and i don't want to sound like a
goddamn kiss ass but yeah it was
freaking awesome
so much of this uh character is in the
body language and you can feel so much
history and i'm curious like what was
your research approach to the character
and also how much did you build that we
didn't even get to touch on that perhaps
you'd like to share some of
we
we i say we built because to me the
favorite my favorite part of the movie
is the comanche count and that i mean we
spent
like the boys and i spent four weeks in
a training camp together before we
started the film and then we shot in the
comanche camp for so long and i think
that that on its own could be a whole
hour and a half of uh you know of a
three-hour movie like i think that is
like all of them had like really
developed characters and really strong
things and
and dynamics among the different
characters and stuff like that that i
think is
is really neat and unique and then as
far as just like naru herself i really
found a lot of importance in her
dad who they talked who like they
touched on like oh cool there's stuff
like that but like that when i like
first started because that was like the
first scene that i ever read was where
they talk about that and so like going
forward like that became kind of a
really big pinnacle to me was like her
father who was a hunter who left his
tools and she was
not over and like he was gone and even
though she has a brother she still feels
the need to do this and like i always
thought was a really interesting part of
her that is not explored in the movie
yeah and i i i remember that moment that
like look exchanging you had with your
mom and that in that scene and that did
stand out to me and that was like the
body language and i was like oh my god i
could feel so much history there so i
really i really appreciate that answer
did all that homework built on that is
so cool yeah so you you play amber's
brother in this movie and i thought that
there was so much like unspoken yet yet
sometimes spoken sincerity and
authenticity with your relationship and
i'm curious as actors how did you two go
about building a relationship
when there's not exactly a lot of
exposition to talk about that history
yeah you know for me well we did the
four week boot camp before the show so
we got to spend a lot of time together
me and amber and the boys um and also we
all hung out like all that we were on
the same hotel like just a few floors
apart so we would all be chilling you
know in each other's rooms just chatting
hanging out playing music so that was a
really helpful to me
but one thing for me i wanted it to be
not just jealous older brother i wanted
to be to be a caring you know he's
strong he's papa bear he's you know but
he also cares about his sister and her
well-being and also her doing what she
wants to do i thought that all really
communicated some of my favorite moments
in this movie are those tender scenes
i've never cared about predator
characters so much before like i gotta i
gotta make that clear so i think you
guys really excelled in that for
me i i wanna say i i'm no comanche
nation expert yet this film reads up so
much authenticity and i heard there's a
i heard there's the comanche dub voice
by the actors and in your honest opinion
would you say that is the preferred way
or the best way to experience this movie
even though it's a dub that is
that really is you know that's the way
that dan originally pitched it you know
the script was written uh and it said
what did it say dan to to be yeah when
you see everything from here on out is
spoken in comanche yeah so and me coming
on as a producer i'm like oh you had me
at comanche so you know perfect right
perfect world perfect world i'm gonna
make sure to watch it again in that
fashion and then like 10 more times as
well so yeah
that sounds great i'm a fan of this
franchise there's a lot of quotes in the
original predator film and i don't want
to spoil it here
you were given a line that i was like he
said it he said the lie
how many retakes did you do you think
you maybe did on that and did you ever
have difficulty getting the original
delivery out of your head oh man we
probably did five to ten uh
okay okay you know just because that's
you know that's the line you know for me
that was so exciting i saw it because
that was originally that originally
wasn't there they might have i think
they might have had it in another spot
and before that they didn't actually
have it there but then when i read the
sides that the previous day i saw that
on there and i was like
[Laughter]
too much too much pressure yeah i know i
was so excited bro nah man you made it
your own i thought it was i thought it
was really excellent i mean it sounds
like you're a fan of this franchise so
like other than the original predator
and of course this movie uh which
predator installment would you say is
your favorite i really you know the
second one was cool
uh danny glover i like danny glover a
lot he's got a good presence but you
know that that scene i think it was in
predators where that guy goes head to
toe with uh her head you know toe-to-toe
with uh the samurai sword yes yes it was
yeah i thought that was pretty wicked
you're more badass in this movie i'm not
just sitting i'm not being hyperbolic
here
this is a hell of a film and in many
ways
the predator films are exploitation
movies but this also feels like a rare
opportunity to tell an earnest story
from a time and perspective we don't see
much of in the mainstream
so what was the key for you guys in your
discussions and balancing like the
sci-fi thrills and kills that like
damage is talking about
but also do it with like tastefully
telling a story about and depicting the
culture of the comanche nation yeah man
it was that that was that was the thing
that was the reason to make was being
able to tell a movie that could work on
a totally visceral level and that also
could have heart to it so it's that the
violence could be beautiful that wasn't
just a part of certainly there's there's
there's the template it follows it's not
that much unlike the original predator
movie we start out in one kind of movie
and it becomes
something else and this version of it is
is just a historical adventure movie
from the from the jump and uh and i try
to never leave that adventure template
as much as i could i really love the
idea of having that kind of having a
little bit of swashbuckle having someone
sliding around and in in quote-unquote
quicksand and that kind of thing yeah
but even when the predator shows up and
the violence
um happens i try i mean i i mean i know
that i needed to deliver on
the way in which it unleashes its might
and and the way it smites but i really
hope that there was still a way to be
somewhat elegant with the way that it
kills and so
even though it's very gory and very
rated there's a lot that is
not seen um up close you know there's
there's i think though it uses
its shield against someone in a tree
and we hide we show some things but we
hide other things in that in that moment
um that's sort of the ethos for what i
wanted to do was like sometimes we're
very interfaced with the with the more
visceral qualities of the movie and
sometimes we're being quite the there's
there's samurai like you know kurosawa
like moments um so i tried to always
have a little bit if i could say
elegance um even in the violent
sequences it's something that i i
learned from doing 10 cloverfield lane
um that i always wish i could have done
a better job of the movie that movie was
one kind of movie and then it becomes
something else and i think in the
filmmaking i shifted gears and i wish i
hadn't as much um and even in the
lensing because i had this other thing
in mind that's too long too long a story
to tell right now it felt like the movie
shifted and i really
wanted to make sure that no matter what
kind of scene knew that this is a genre
mashup filmmaking's still the same kind
of style throughout the throughout the
movie so it isn't just like it's
handheld in the beginning and then it's
still late you know like it all still
feels like it's from the same authorship
i thought the build up and handling of
perspective and transitioning was just
absolutely excellent
and uh i love technical field late so i
don't know what you're talking about
everything could be bad huh
thank you
max and i i know that you're a director
yourself
was there anything in particular that
you learned from dan that you think you
could take it to your next project well
you really did your research i respect
it
i am not i directed like two short films
when i was like
17 so i would not call myself a director
but i call you a director
i appreciate the cred i mean i feel like
no that if that is something that is in
my future i think it's very very it's
not out of the question but i think it's
so far in the future because i have so
much respect for what
dan does and his job i think it's just
so big and so consuming and i think to
craft to be the leader of a ship like
this and to craft an entire film and
have it be good from you know
pre-production to shooting to like to
post and
giving it to everybody i think it's like
i just think it's so incredible and i
think there's so many facets to what he
does is amazing and watching him do it
was i definitely learned so much from
him but i think there's no way that i
could think that like i could do that
you know because i think that
he in particular is just incredibly
gifted uh this is
for what i see that this is your first
major film role
and it's both part of like a huge modern
franchise and it's also a cultural
period piece so obviously that's a
really real like fortunate position you
earned your way into but what overall
has this experience meant to you oh man
well you know i've always wanted to act
but i honestly you know i was a musician
and i didn't really know if it was in
the cards because i didn't know anybody
in the industry and i didn't know how to
get into the industry um so i thought
maybe if i'm a really good musician i'll
get like a hallmark movie and then i'll
like build my way up just to get this
experience on a multi-million dollar
movie a good movie you know with good
director good people good cast good
producer
um it was so educational and it just
makes you i mean i want to continue
doing this as long as i can so just the
experience was
educational but enjoyable your first
movie 10 cloverfield lane you have a
female character who has to overcome a
lot of internal and external fear and
come into a place of their own with true
strength you also have something of a
similar parallel here is there something
in particular you're drawn to about
female 1 i definitely
am
interested in sort of conquering the
perception of
someone who would that something that
would not be strong them conquering that
perception
mainly because that's how i feel um
that's how i have felt my whole life so
cinematically that's a little bit more
linked to that kind of protagonist so
that that i think is where it comes from
i think i found that i've gotten a lot
of strength from
my mom and my wife their influence on me
perhaps more so than other men in my
life or that that i that i've been
friends whatever it is you know and
that's a big part of the story that's a
little bit more under the surface is a
story about someone who's rejecting the
wisdom from her mother who wants her to
do medicine and she's doing all this
other stuff and the thing that really
saves her butt is embracing what the mom
gave her um so it isn't just about can a
girl
become like a guy you know it's more
about like
you need to embrace all the things being
a strong part being the alpha being the
top dog it's not just
who has the biggest muscles which by the
way predator is kind of about that too
the original um it's not that far off
from it so it's just coming in from a
different angle i thought you absolutely
nailed it i even told amber actually
that i was like i've never cared so much
about a about a character in the
predator franchise before so it was
accidentally done i gave up meat because
of my love for animals and i read that
you also have a passion for animal
rights yes
something i actually wasn't prepared for
uh was the amount of animal deaths in
this movie and i know it's all like
pretend and effects but was any of that
difficult to participate in or watch
back in the final cut it's interesting i
think that
the way that i feel about animal rights
is different from other people who maybe
feel that way because it's like i'm not
i'm not vegan like i eat meat i love
meat all that stuff i tried for a while
and it honestly was just like not my
body is like not built for that like i
really totally get it a good try and it
was not happening i've put a lot of
thought into this because that was
definitely like a large passion that i
had especially when i was like a
teenager and like into my early like
around like you know 2021 and and animal
rights is
it's it's so largely about like the way
i think also that we like view animals
and we treat like
wild animals like it's like and you live
it i think people find different ways to
live it so like the way that like i
live that in my life is like i don't use
any like cosmetics or like skincare
products or anything like or household
items that are like tested
like that's where i find that you know
and it's like even on shows like i'm
sure to like tell my makeup artist like
you know that's really like hey this is
kind of my boundary and stuff like that
so yeah but i think that there's also a
way that it's like that's also kind of
like the natural order of life going
back historically
we always ate meat it was just done with
like a much more
i think like respectful and mindful way
of like you know taking lives and like
not wasting anything and like also they
had a good like animals had good lives
like while they were living it's not
like now when it's like i don't know
chickens are raising like you know stuff
like that like it's just like bad and
stuff like that but i mean i do still
like eat meat and stuff i've just found
like yeah yeah it's hard to live all of
it at once i feel like as far as like
conscious consumption just in general i
feel like you have to like pick a few
things and then go with that you know
otherwise you can get so overwhelmed
trying to like
save everything all the time and then
you're
failing but no i think i've just found
like i stick to those things no i
appreciate that honest answer i'm not as
like particular about the products but
more about the food yeah yeah yeah pick
and choose especially actually i asked
you about the movie that too
while we're at it but i really really
love that answer um would you say that
music is your first passion uh before
before acting and what kind of music do
you do uh it's kind of like a country
americana kind of thing not the uh not
the annoying pro country but like you
know like kind of old school
you know and i would i would like to con
i'd like to continue on both of them to
be honest they don't want to necessarily
give one a priority over the other
uh i certainly don't plan on giving
either one up maybe putting one to the
side for a moment depending on what kind
of opportunities arise but i i will
definitely be doing my best to continue
acting as long as i can that's so great
to hear i can't wait to see more uh very
sincerely because it's actually one of
my things when i was watching this movie
was i really noted how reflective of the
emotion the music was in this film so
like what was your take on the oh yeah
you know the music is like it's always
been a big part of me uh for film like
watching if the music is bad it drives
me crazy but the first time i saw the
movie uh there's this tune called like
nadu's journey or something like that
but it's so cool i just love that they
weren't they didn't overdo it with the
drums and the flutes you know i'm saying
they like you know they had some strings
in there i was just so pleasantly
surprised you know
because you you know you never know like
how things are gonna turn out but when i
first heard it i was just happy oh yeah
no it made my heart move it always
created the suspense and the tension it
was beautiful but
uh seriously man uh you have so much to
be proud of here and i love this movie i
genuinely love your performance i know i
loved it because i got nervous to speak
to you so thank you for being such a
cool dude to talk to man thank you for
oh thank you bro i really appreciate it
i think i'm you're on youtube yeah yeah
i'm on youtube i might have seen i might
have seen did you do a reaction video to
us yeah it's the trailer yeah i was so
into it and i was like
yeah
i think i saw that no yeah
i appreciate that thank you brother
definitely thank you so much i really
enjoyed uh talking with you i love how
we didn't even talk about any predator
related things i think that's so cool i
love everything that we actually spoke
about
this is really a great time and uh major
major congratulations to you and thank
you for being so courteous and open and
vulnerable while we were talking i
really appreciate you thank you so much
all right take care
seriously
thank you we have a great predator
moving in it's something it was even
more than that thank you thank you both
thank you so much keep on doing what
you're doing too man thank you thank you
take care
[Music]